did you know that there's a mysterious
area in space where astronauts are
unable to communicate with home base
they're exposed to extreme levels of
radiation and their spaceships start to
malfunction
it's being dubbed the Bermuda Triangle
of space this area has perplexed
scientists for decades but astronomers
may have finally solved this outer space
anomaly
what exactly is the Bermuda Triangle of
space anyway
well its official name is the South
Atlantic anomaly or SAA for short it's
hovering above the South Atlantic
stretching from Chile to Zimbabwe and
this area has a considerably weaker
magnetic field when compared to the rest
of the Van Allen radiation belt the Van
Allen radiation belt is a pair of cosmic
Donuts surrounding Earth this is a
unique location where the radiation belt
comes closest to the Earth's surface
these belts trap particles that shoot
from the sun which protects the Earth
from harmful radiation the solar
radiation within the South Atlantic
anomaly isn't held back to the same
degree though but why well to explain
that first let's dive into what happens
if you wander into this terrifying part
of our solar system
you know trying to solve this Bermuda
Triangle of space it really sparked a
mystery craving for the what if team so
we played Hunter Killers dead below deck
at a recent games day this game is
filled with suspicious characters and
intriguing evidence all of which had us
feeling like we were the world's
greatest detectives the game doesn't
have any rules and it doesn't have any
time constraints it's just you and your
friends a slew of Clues and a mystery
waiting to be unraveled my favorite part
was how immersive it was some versions
even have things like AI chats and real
actors to make the game more interactive
they've got single box cases multi-part
sagas and six or 12 month subscriptions
and if you ever get stuck you just hit
up the spoiler-free online community for
help it's ideal for game nights dates
family fun whatever you want get your
dead below deck game from Amazon Target
or Walmart today and thanks to Hunter
Killer for sponsoring this episode
now let's see if we can solve this space
Bermuda Triangle mystery the SAA is
known for causing electronic
malfunctions in spaceships and extreme
radiation exposure for astronauts it can
completely destroy spacecraft in 2016
the Japanese satellite Hitomi Came
Crashing Down to Earth after satellite
operators began getting mixed signals
from the ship it was reporting
inaccurate data about how it was
performing up in space making people
down on Earth think that everything was
fine but this was happening as it
traveled through the SAA so operators
weren't aware that there was a problem
and couldn't take steps to correct it
the Hubble telescope luckily has managed
to avoid any issues while traveling
through the SAA that's despite spending
a whopping 15 percent of its time in the
space anomaly to protect the telescope
satellite operators power it down if
they didn't the SAA could corrupt any
precious data that's been collected and
potentially crash
but how do astronauts deal with these
heavy levels of radiation
well their radiation levels are
constantly being monitored so if they do
end up in the anomaly they have what's
known as a water wall certain rooms on
ships are filled with these massive bags
of water and if you stand behind them
they'll protect you from radiation water
is the best thing to Shield you from
this harmful energy because of its high
hydrogen content now if they didn't have
this water wall they could get severe
radiation poisoning or even cancer
so we know the radiation levels are much
higher and more dangerous in this
specific part of space but why is it
happening in the first place
well despite what pictures might show
you Earth isn't completely round it
bulges around the center like me and
because of this the Earth's physical
Center and its magnetic Center are
slightly off by about 500 kilometers
this offset means things like cosmic
rays can get closer to the Earth's
surface near the bulging area luckily
the Earth's magnetic bubble can still
keep all those dangerous rays from
getting to us but that's not the case
for people in space above the South
Atlantic because of this stronger
radiation levels can reach this point up
in space and what's even more concerning
due to the fact that the magnetic poles
here on Earth are constantly changing
the South Atlantic anomaly keeps growing
it's also gotten weaker by 15 meaning
the radiation has gotten stronger in the
area
so NASA has been carefully monitoring
the SAA since 2019. they've noticed that
the anomaly is moving West and what's
even weirder the anomaly is also
splitting in two if this continues it
could make things even more complicated
regarding space travel and data
collection but luckily for it to change
significantly would take Millions if not
billions of years
so this Bermuda Triangle of space isn't
as mysterious as it sounds and
astronomers are getting better at
handling it with every new ship launch
and every piece of data recorded
this would probably become a way bigger
problem if the Earth's magnetic poles
suddenly flipped
but that's a story for another
what if
foreign